[Musique]
vous avez commencé votre journée vous
êtes connecté à internet
c'est de regarder facebook instagram
peut-être une vidéo youtube en fait on
est même commencer cet après midi avec
une vidéo youtube prise sur internet
et puis bah en fin de journée vous allez
peut-être aller sur wikipédia pour en
apprendre un peu plus sur quelque chose
que vous aurez attendus aujourd'hui et
qui vous aura intéressé
juste pour être sûr que ça arrive je
vous donnais un petit fun fact rené
goscinny le scénariste d'astérix est
mort en fait d'un arrêt cardiaque en
faisant un test d'endurance chez son
cardiologue
si roddick mais n'empêche pour 4
milliard de personnes sur terre ce cette
routine de tous les jours que vous avez
elle n'est pas possible
alors oui tout de suite vous allez me
dire effectivement si on est au sahara
au sommet d'une montagne on n'aura pas
de problème on aura un problème de
connectivité on n'aura pas de réseau et
tout ça d'un côté je vous dirai pas
vraiment 4 milliard de personnes au
sahara et de nos jours surtout la
majorité de la population mondiale vit
dans des villes
donc c'est plus un problème de coût et
aussi d'infrastructures que cet accès à
internet par exemple à cuba une heure de
connexion dans un cybercafé ou dans un
parc coûtera 1 $ pour vous pour moi un
dollar c'est pas grand chose à cuba
c'est une journée de salaire
donc on peut se dire que les cubains de
fait sont pas ou mal
connecté puis un deuxième phénomène
auquel on pense pas vraiment et qui est
pourtant en croissance et c'est un
problème c'est le gouvernement qui
décide pour votre bien qui va censurer
les réseaux je vous rassure c'est
toujours pour votre bien la preuve à
l'an dernier en ethiopie ils ont coupé
en fait l'accès internet pendant la
durée des examens d'entrée à
l'université pour éviter que les
étudiants triche qui sont présents du
coup j'en profite pour faire un petit
aparté c'est que si aujourd'hui vous
pouvez avoir tout ce que vous devriez
apprendre par coeur
au bout de votre main vous avez plus
besoin d'apprendre par coeur donc les
enfants d'aujourd'hui eux devront
apprendre à réfléchir quand nous on a
juste après a répété fonds saisis la
prochaine fois vous moquerez de leurs
boutons passe
en fait ils sont plus mal et puis une
troisième raison que cette fois qui va
vous touchez d'un peu plus près ces
raisons technologiques c'est une
contrainte technologique
c'est en fait de loi il s'appelle la loi
de moore et l'autre de nilsen la loi de
moore en fait elle nous dit que tous les
18 mois
vous allez doubler la puissance de
l'ordinateur que vous pouvez vous payer
pour le même prix donc concrètement se
dire que vous achetez un téléphone
portable aujourd'hui dans 18 mois le
modèle suivant arrivera etc pourront la
progression technologique
de fait les contenus vous allez pouvoir
générer avec ses téléphones la qualité
des images vous allez produire pour être
aussi dans ton plus gros la loi 2000
scène elle parle justement des données
que vous allez pouvoir transmettre l
part de la bande passante elle nous dit
tous les 21 mois
la bande passante va doubler également
donc on pourra transmettre deux fois
plus de données avec les mêmes files les
mêmes réseaux wifi c'est très bien
jusqu'à ce que vous disiez hockey d'un
côté et 18 mois sa double et de l'autre
côté main thermos à double donc
forcément il ya ce trois mois qui
constitue un goulot d'étranglement et
qui fait qu' il y aura toujours un
problème de connectivité même dans les
endroits les mieux connectés
et puis comme n'importe quelle histoire
finalement l humain vraiment réel quand
elle est vraiment personnel et qu'est ce
qui a plus de personnel finalement
qu'une maman on a eu cette situation où
maman est à la campagne
imaginez la lozère 1 dimanche en hiver
ce genre de connectivité et maman un
fils qui est programmeur les programmes
et informaticiens et dit maman et un
truc génial ça s'appelle wikipedia c'est
la réponse à toutes les questions
notamment sur le signe et puis il arrive
comment sa démonstration ça ne marche
pas heureusement les programmeurs
informaticiens si on va chercher une
solution internet ne vient pas maman
maman veut pas déménager est donc allé à
internet
donc on va enlever internet de
l'équation est finalement qu'est ce qui
nous reste nous reste la solution la
solution c'est le contenu
donc il est créé un programme qui
s'appelle kiwix wikipedia wiki kiwi bien
x ça c'est cool et kiwix finalement va
télécharger ce contenu donc un endroit
où vous avez une bonne connexion il va
le mettre localement un petit fichier
qui conviendra à tous
vous voulez un site contenu comme
wikipedia par exemple pour ensuite le
promener avec vous l'emmenez sur une clé
usb ou sur votre téléphone
maintenant les plus de stockage sont
vraiment pas cher et puis comme ça vous
allez pouvoir montrer à maman les
merveilles de ce monde
et puis comme une assez généreux il dit
j'aime bien sur internet s'il ya
d'autres gens parlant avec propre maman
et leurs propres problèmes de
connectivité qui pourront en profiter
qu'ils pourront faire exactement pareil
que moi aujourd'hui on a 3 millions
d'utilisateurs ils étaient un million et
demi l'an dernier on en attend 4 à 5
millions l'an prochain s'il comptait
l'électricité les serveurs les frais ça
nous revient à peu près à 1 centime par
personne donc autant dire que c'est
gratuit donc on a eu des utilisations
dans ces trois millions qu'on attendait
quelque part avec lesquels on a
travaillé la fondation orange par
exemple l'opérateur téléphonique
montrent ce qu'ils appellent des écoles
numériques en afrique vous arrive dans
un village qui n'a ni téléphone ni
électricité ils construisent avec des
matériaux locaux ils embauchent 1 1 un
instituteur et puis ils amènent des
panneaux solaires examine un petit
serveur local qui crée un petit réseau
local est en fait en 2018 sachez le
c'est moins cher d'offrir à ses enfants
une petite tablette à 30 dollars à
fabriquer en chine que d'acheter un
livre pour chaque matière et pour chaque
enfant
le calcul économique est là qu'on aide à
une période de notre vie de l'humanité
où c'est moins cher finalement d'avoir
de la haute technologie
autre exemple à côté de nous en suisse
en allemagne aux états unis
la formation pour les prisonniers qui
font des longues peines
on part du calcul qui ont effectivement
c'est bien de les mettre en prison mais
c'est encore mieux si il est vide il
revenir donc on leur apprend un métier
mais comme ils sont en prison pas de
connectivité et à nouveau on utilise
kiwix et les méthodes hors ligne pour
leur donner une chance de redémarrer
mais aussi les utilisations qu'on
n'avait pas prévu
si vous connaissez la corée un pays
formidable où on fait des jeux
olympiques au sud et on est puni pour
les avoir regardés au nar
il y à des dissidents nord coréens qui
ont donc fui leur pays qui se retrouvent
au sud et qui décide d'y retourner
il retourne pas les mains vides il
retourne encore une fois des petites
l'usb sur lesquels on a minima qui paie
dia en coréen des séries télévision de
genre france des soap opera n'importe
quoi finalement la culture locale il
passe par la chine puisque la frontière
avec la corée du nord c'est c'est une
simple rivière donc ce fils nager et
puis ils perdent leurs clés usb dans la
rue alors pourquoi il les perdre parce
que finalement la corée du nord c'est
pas si pauvre que ça il ya une élite qui
disposent d'ordinateurs évidemment il
tente pas sur windows mais sur quelque
chose qui s'appelle étoile rouge
notamment mais qui permet de lire qui
oui c'est finalement bas ces gens ils
sont curieux quand même trouvé une clé
usb dans la rue surtout là-bas c'est pas
banal donc sur le tas ils vont regarder
ce qu'il ya dessus puis vont
s'apercevoir que le monde que le
gouvernement leur décrit c'est pas le
vrai monde
c'est la meilleure propagande au final
c'est celle qui est vrai et ça marche
plutôt bien ils ont distribué environ
60000 clés par an et puis non plus
d'engager ils ont jeté un drone qui fait
les livraisons à quelqu'un qui récupère
de l'autre côté si vous souvenez du
tournant du siècle on nous disait
l'homme sera sur mars en 2020 bon
on n'est pas pressé et le monde s'est
pas arrêté de tourner pour autant et
c'est pareil pour internet
on vous dit vous avez internet vous
l'avez pas vous la cage et la 5g
vous l'avez pas et à ce moment où
acteurs du nom le monde c'est pas des
perdants et des gagnants
au final ce que vous voulez c'est pas
l'outil c'est l' usage que cet outil
vous apportera vous voulez
cette connaissance est maintenant on
peut tous l'avoir merci
[Applaudissements]